hello one hello wall is coming to the
end of the year which meat series are
recovering from hangovers from Christmas
or you're about to recover from a
hangover from New Year's other than that
it means it's time for my list of my top
ten favorite movies of 2018 and as
always as I say every year as a
disclaimer I haven't seen every movie in
the year I never do and this is not a
review for the movies I'm gonna give a
quick synopsis as to why I chose it but
every movie on this list has a review by
me you can find it here on YouTube also
this year you might notice I cut back on
the awesome tacular rating that's
because years prior I started giving
those things out and made it rain
awesome tacular and looking back a few
times admittedly I'm like I'd scale that
back to buy it on blu-ray so I wanted to
err on the side of caution this year but
gave an awesome tacular I wanted to mean
it and if I gave buy it on blu-ray who
knows at this point maybe it's moved up
to awesome tacular or maybe i put a buy
it on blu-ray above an awesome tacular
just to blow some minds we shall find
out today before we get started we're
gonna start with number 10 of course
number 10 is the hardest number on the
top 10 Louis isn't it because number 10
is the numbers the placement that tells
people what do you mean it this way or
not it says I'm good enough to be on the
list but I'm not better than the other
movies on the list so by implication I'm
better than everything that didn't make
the list I don't know 10 is just hard
for me and also keep in mind these
movies on this list are not my opinion
no they are the top 10 technically
perfect Nathan
Wallace movies of 2018 starting with no
Beaute starting the list at number 10 we
have upgrade I really hope you guys
still recognize sarcasm when you see it
like we thought about 10 seconds ago
I've been doing this for a while if you
don't know the gist of my channel and my
taste well welcome this is kind of the
embodiment of it upgrade was a new spin
on the revenge tale I really dug it I
feel like it was the better version of
venom I'm a longtime fan of the Outer
Limits in the Twilight Zone and this
reminded me of a feature-length film
version of an episode of the Outer
Limits of The Twilight Zone I really dug
that and I dug up grade coming in at
number nine we have Creed - I feel like
there are two kinds of people in the
world people who prefer rocky to - rocky
one and people who prefer rock you hon -
rocky - maybe the same thing goes for
creed I don't know I feel like Creed one
was a better film than creative but
Creed two was a solid sequel it was damn
watchable everyone did a good job in the
movie and it's an interesting revenge
tale really revenge tale without the
killing part actually started with a
killing part but still really loved
those Creed movies they should stop at
this point though no more Creed
next up we have a movie that a lot of
people were like it's okay it's pretty
mediocre and I was like those [ __ ]
Ozlem Ralph breaks the internet
parentheses wreck-it ralph to this movie
spoke to me maybe he's because what I do
for a living I love the continuation of
Ralph and vanellope friendship and story
and this movie made Diggs on YouTube the
YouTube model the online space in
general things I see a lot of and
they're really frustrating but that's
like I'm so glad that I dress that if
you want to know how to make a big on
YouTube this movie is not wrong the
video game element which I love so much
in the first wreck-it Ralph movie kind
of took a backseat in this movie to the
main plot and it didn't bother me that's
shocking to me next we have searching
searching was interesting a movie
basically filmed on skype or a phone
little bit of Google Maps or Waze thrown
in there it's a missing person's movie
told from the perspective that someone
in this situation would really see it
through maybe you're seeing it through
the perspective of phones or news this
movie swung for the fences trying
something new this was like the first
time I ever saw a found footage movie
where I was like oh wow that's
interesting that's new that's it feels
more real and alive because it's
supposed you granted the found-footage
genre has been pounded into the dirt but
this gave a new spin on that I hope
movies don't take this premise and do it
over and over and over again would you
they will have given the opportunity
there's one of those movies I told
people I'm like you totally need to see
this movie there's no way it was missing
my top ten six next up we have
spider-man into the spider-verse
spider-man into the spider verse wasn't
my real introduction to Miles Morales
that was actually the ps4 game very
recently when I played it I was like oh
wow I'm interested in this kid I didn't
know much about him but yeah give me
more into the spider verse was more and
I walked out of that movie going what
have I been missing why haven't I known
more about Miles Morales I want to read
more of his comic books now this was a
pure spider-man adventure and I love the
fact that they incorporated the spider
verse I feel like you're never gonna see
that in a live-action movie I don't know
why oh look at that
animated Spider Man there's a really
legit way to do spider-man kind of
through back to the 90s animation I
really dug when they had spider version
good news is me being relatively new to
Miles Morales a story in life anything
that people are like oh I know what's
coming
I didn't see coming if you're a
spider-man fan even if you don't know or
care about Miles Morales give him a shot
you will be hooked fine Avengers
infinity war was an experience it was
the culmination of the past 10 years of
the MCU
I've been along for that in
I arrived the first time I saw Ironman I
was like that was way better than it
probably should have been and after a
ten-year cinematic build the likes of
which we've never seen before in our
lifetime and even before your lifetimes
cinematic history itself never had
anything like the MCU building up to
Avengers infinity war I thought it was
some great payoff granted we still have
Avengers endgame I'm not discounting
that as what would be the final chapter
and even after that they're gonna have
more so even final chapter doesn't mean
final chapter or news it was building up
the fan o Stannis came saw conquered on
the screen there were other movies that
might have hit me more emotional and
we'll talk about them in a second but
for now Avengers infinity war it built
up to this it led to this and we had pay
off with this and for me the movie was
even better the second time I saw it
because the things I was maybe expecting
maybe the things I didn't buy the first
time you let slide to just enjoy the
ride and I enjoy the hell out of this
ride next up we have a star is born yes
remember a second ago and I said other
movies might have hit me on a more
emotional level this stop moving man oh
man this movie was really good Bradley
Cooper is great in it Lady Gaga's
greatness it's a great movie about a
building relationship it's a great movie
about a building career it's a great
movie about the fall of a career it's a
great movie about not losing yourself to
the Hollywood monster
it's a [ __ ] real thing I lived there
for a year it is it's so easy to lose
yourself you got to dip your toe in and
[ __ ] bail and by the end I was crying
not ashamed to admit it next is a quiet
place we see the trailers - a quiet
place you're interested and that's all
you can go into this movie with is
curiosity because dialogue not a big
part of the trailer not a big part of
the movie because it makes you stop and
think you never stop and think how
difficult it is to live and survive and
not make noise the inability to make
noise that really hamstrings you and
your survival I mean I'm loud as [ __ ]
I'd have been in the first wave of
deaths gone the good news is I guess I
don't have to worry about living in a
world like this but you can touch
breathing in the theater a lot of the
audience just holding their breath for
most the time afraid to make any peep
any noise it was the most peaceful
cinematic watch I ever had with the
general audience anyone who made a P the
mob was gonna riot I have a soft spot
for horror thrillers interesting and
unique concepts John Krasinski crushed
it in the acting Department and the
directing Department can't wait to see
what he does next - next up won't you be
my neighbor when I saw this movie I was
like that's gonna be number one
right it's just such a damn feel-good
movie in a world with such vitriol such
iron it's just the best word I can
describe the internet space the world in
general everywhere you look people are
fighting whether it's like movies are
you a DC fan or a Marvel fan because
we're politics even movies that used to
be escapism they're not escapism
escapism less and less these days anyway
I feel like won't you be my neighbor was
just a pure sense of joy I needed this
movie like when Captain America was
talking to Phil Coulson and the Avengers
and he said something about his suit
being very old-fashioned Coulson was
like I think people could use a little
bit of old-fashioned that's what this
movie was it was that concept brought to
the big screen my life goes to be like
that dude I never will be I'm Way too
crass I'm Way too much of a dick doesn't
mean I can't admire and this movie he
gave me hope for Humanity here we are
number one my number one pick this is
the movie that if walked out of going
yeah this was the movie of the summer
for me this might piss some people off I
have no idea but Mission Impossible fall
out that was a great time at the movies
which is what I was looking for we had a
couple of great movies of summer we had
a lot of movies it just fell short by
the end of the year I felt like I was
gonna make a top 7 list the Mission
Impossible fall out slick cool
action-packed the action sequences were
amazing Mission Impossible is like the
cooler version of James Bond right now
really if you look at the Bond movies
they're like awesome horrible awesome
the Mission Impossible Men they're
crushing it and Tom Cruise has still got
it
how dudes over 50 it's crazy like
Russell Crowe and that mummy movies all
liking a young man no he's not that's
what makes him so great most people in
Tom Cruise's situation would have
retired by now not him and as long as he
keeps making this Mission Impossible
movies so kick-ass I really hope he
doesn't retire anytime soon and this
movie was this great I feel like it kind
of gets eclipsed by the whole like oath
annals did this what's the DCE you even
do it now is that even the DCE you now
they're making standalone DC movies oh
[ __ ] Avengers end game when's that
trailer coming out and I love talking
about it all but mission impossible
fallout gave me that feeling without the
franchise I mean use the franchise it's
not a comic book movie franchise mission
impossible fallout comes in it's like
hey I'm [ __ ] kick-ass - don't count
me out and it totally held its own
against the comic book movie titans of
industry and that's why in 2018 it's my
favorite movie of the year alright so as
the year comes to an end that's my list
those my top 10 favorite movies of 2018
if you did
since the sarcasm at the beginning even
after I addressed it was sarcasm not the
technically perfect movies but the ones
that just hit me they hit me where I
live and I love that about these movies
the next video oh yes it's coming the
horror the abominations dog [ __ ] a lot
of movies were absolute ass this year so
I can't wait to give you my list of the
top 10 worst movies of 2018 until then
your top 10 favorite movies of 2018 what
are they whatever they are comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]